[Music]
all right earlier today a fight nearly
broke out between Oklahoma senator Mark
Wayne Mullen and Teamsters Union boss
Shan O'Brien during a senate health
education labor and pensions Committee
hearing here's how it all went down take
a look tweeted at me one two 3
four five times and let me read what the
last one said um it said greedy CEO who
pretends like he's
self-made sir I wish he was in the truck
with me when I was building my plumbing
company myself quit the tough guy act in
these Senate hearings you know where to
find me any place anytime
Cowboy sir this is a time this is a
place you want to run your mouth we can
be to consenting adults we can finish it
here okay that's fine perfect you want
to do it now I'd love to do it right now
well stand your butt up then you stand
your butt up oh hold stop it is that
your solutionary p no no sit down sit
down you know you're a United States
Senator sit down okay sit down
please OK Oklahoma senator Mark Wayne
Mullen joins us right now for more
Senator I got to be honest I don't think
this is going to hurt you with the
people Oklahoma I think po popularity
probably will go up uh tenfold as a
result of that he called you out you
called him out for calling you out and
that's kind of old school the way it
used to be isn't it right yeah it is and
in Oklahoma people tell me I've had
media come out to me and says this is
coming of a senator I was like listen
I'm a guy from Oklahoma first in
Oklahoma you don't do this maybe you run
your mouth in New Jersey I don't know
I'm not I'm not from New Jersey but this
is some Thug that's a mob boss and
you're supposed to be intimidating
because he's the boss of the teamsters
but and he's got away with this he's got
suspended by his own by his own uh
Teamsters before for intimidation he's
been in trouble multiple times he he's
he in 2022 he said he wanted to bring
the mob mentality back to the teamsters
maybe that's true but you still not
going to run your mouth at me and expect
me to just sit there and and you should
have seen the fear of his eyes when I
stood up too I'm not joking I I'm not
looking for a fight I used to get paid
to fight professionally this I'm not
really looking for it but I'm sure not
going to sit back and let somebody do
that and not call them out on it well
let me tell you you know I love these
people on on social media I call them
the keyboard Warriors usually in their
basement you know basement bunkers you
know and they underwear and they're all
tough on on you know social media uh
then you call them out on it they're not
so tough you know it is interesting
though when you think of the left today
you know if you use the wrong pronoun in
school boy the left will Lo absolutely
lose it um when I grew up it was a
little bit of a different time when me
and my friends when we played football
when we played basketball I played
hockey you know I don't think there was
a single day that we were playing sports
where we didn't drop the gloves or you
know have a a brief interlude of you
know throwing fists and it be all be
over you pick up and you start playing
again you know yeah when all of a sudden
did we become that woke that the thought
of two people uh one responding to a
threat directly saying okay you threaten
me here's your opportunity take me up on
it yeah well it's political correctness
it's it's it's all a sudden you got to
worry about somebody's feelings but oh
by the way the left can say whatever
they want and and it's not personal to
me I'm not mad at this guy I mean he
said it I'm just answering the call
that's it if he wants to go out
afterwards and have a cup of coffee
let's go have a cup of coffee I'm
friends with a lot of guys that I used
to fight I I unfortunately I grew up in
I I grew up in the country of Oklahoma
you did the same thing that you did when
you grew up and you settled your issues
and you went on with it and there was no
hard feelings by it well a few times was
hard feelings especially if you if you
won but if you lost you just kind of
took your lickens and you you learn from
it right and this guy I just don't think
that he was expecting uh he was
expecting me to answer the call and um
and and and and we need more of this to
be quite Frank I'm not saying more
violence but we need more people to be
taught a lesson and and be called out on
what they say you got to be responsible
for the words the way I read his his
tweet to you is he called you out he's
the one that said he he wanted this
exchange and all you were doing saying
okay tough guy let's go that's right I
mean uh I think any other response kind
of would have been a little gutless uh
but you know there I would agree with
that I mean what people want me to do if
I didn't do that people in okl Coloma
would be pretty upset at me that's not
how we rais supp represent Oklahoma
values you know I think that actually is
probably true and I think people in
Oklahoma again I'm going to predict that
your approval ratings are probably going
to go higher let's go to the issue of
unions and what you were getting into
today that led up to
this well listen there the unions are up
there because Bernie Sanders is a
socialist that runs our committee and
he's he's in the unions Pockets right or
the pocket unions in his pocket one of
the two and and they were tting about
how good unions are and how good they
are for the country and I'm not against
unions fine if you want to join a union
join a union but there's a reason why 50
years ago 33% of the labor force was in
the union and today it's 10% and there's
a reason why right to work states like
Oklahoma has a
$4,000 a year salary higher than Union
states it's because Choice matters and
people want to make a decision on how
they work and where their money goes and
by the way these unions take Rank and
file money and they use it for political
C uh reasons often to help Democrats get
elected that that is contrary to the
vales of uh the values of rank and file
so that's right uh anyway I don't know
if you guys get in the Octagon I would
volunteer I'll gladly be the ref I'll
call my buddy Dana White see if he can't
work it into one of his uh UFC events
and you guys hit the Octagon I'll be the
referee and you guys can have at it
let's see how tough he is in the Octagon
I think see it happen I don't think
you'll do it though we do a pay-per-view
for charity I think it' be interesting
that's right I love it appreciate
appreciate it Senator thank you you hey
Sean Hannity here hey here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else